[Música]
bienvenidos a en 5 minutos donde
intentamos explicar de manera sencilla
asuntos complicados el mundo vive una
emergencia climática
[Música]
miles de hectáreas ardiendo en
california a la amazonía grecia turquía
lluvias torrenciales olas de calor
huracanes ríos desbordados o ciudades
inundadas a qué se deben estos fenómenos
cada vez más frecuentes qué papel juega
el cambio climático en ellos y cuál es
el llamado de los expertos comencemos
por aclarar los términos cambio
climático y calentamiento global muchas
veces se usan como sinónimos pero no lo
son en realidad uno es consecuencia del
otro veamos a qué se deben a nuestro
modelo de consumo y producción
industrial nos ha llevado a quemar
enormes cantidades de combustibles
fósiles como la gasolina el carbón o el
gas natural el dióxido de carbono que
liberan estos combustibles se almacena
en la atmósfera impidiendo que la
radiación solar que entra a la tierra y
que trae calor salga del planeta estos
son los famosos gases de efecto
invernadero y son la causa de la
retención de más y más calor en la
atmósfera lo que provoca una subida de
la temperatura media del planeta y esto
en sí es el calentamiento global
este calentamiento de la tierra genera
fuertes perturbaciones en el clima del
planeta y estas alteraciones son el
cambio climático recientemente naciones
unidas describió la situación como un
código rojo para la humanidad y es que
el aumento de la temperatura y sus
efectos no son un problema del futuro ya
estamos viviendo sus consecuencias entre
no menos extremos como las olas de calor
inéditas que no surgen por casualidad a
qué se debe viendo con mayor temperatura
en el planeta los días de verano o
cálidos ahora se hacen mucho más
evidentes con temperaturas recortes de
más de 40 grados o incluso de 50 grados
en muchos lugares ahora veamos los
incendios estos a priori no son malos de
hecho muchos ecosistemas los necesitan
para renovarse el problema es que cada
vez hay más son más grandes y acaban con
ecosistemas enteros y como los afecta al
calentamiento global el aumento de las
temperaturas reseca al extremo los
bosques y una vegetación seca es más
propensa a arder con rapidez el
calentamiento global también altera el
ciclo de las estaciones lo que hace que
las temporadas incendios sean más largas
otro fenómeno preocupante y según la onu
inevitable es la subida del nivel del
mar veamos por qué con un clima más
caliente se derriten en los cielos
terrestres desde 1880 con el inicio de
la era industrial el nivel del mar ha
aumentado entre 21 y 24 centímetros y un
tercio de este aumento se ha producido
en los últimos 25 años según naciones
unidas el nivel del mar seguirá
creciendo a lo largo del siglo 21 y esto
es peligroso para las ciudades costeras
muchas de ellas en donde viven y
trabajan millones de personas
este aumento es preocupante también por
su fuerte impacto en el efecto albedo
del planeta que es el porcentaje de
radiación o sea de calor que cada
superficie refleja o expulsan por
ejemplo la nieve tiene una capacidad de
reflejo del 86 por ciento mientras que
la del océano es sólo del 6% así que
menos glaciares es igual a más agua en
el mar y por consecuencia a más calor en
la tierra ahora vamos a los huracanes
estos se forman y se fortalecen en
partes del océano con aguas calientes y
el calentamiento del agua provoca que
los vientos huracanados se vuelvan más
rápidos y más grandes haciendo que estos
fenómenos sean cada vez más arrasadores
como el huracán katrina que arrasó nueva
orleans en 2005 o elliot a que devastó
centroamérica en 2020
ahora veamos las lluvias torrenciales el
calentamiento global causa que cada vez
más agua se evapore y suba las nubes
esto se traduce en mega aguaceros que
dejan zonas inundadas en cuestión de
horas
por ejemplo en julio de 2021 a la
provincia del genal en china recibió el
equivalente a casi un año de lluvia en
tres días más de 300 personas murieron y
este mismo año las inundaciones en
alemania y bélgica dejaron más de 200
muertos para hacernos una idea desde la
revolución industrial el planeta se ha
calentado un grados celsius y si
seguimos con el modelo actual el de
consumo y energías no renovables el
planeta podría calentarse para finales
de siglo hasta 4 grados y si los efectos
ya se hacen sentir solo queda imaginar
que nos esperan por ello los expertos
piden con urgencia a cambiar el modelo
energético en el acuerdo de parís las
potencias del mundo se comprometieron a
mantener por debajo de los dos grados
celsius la temperatura del planeta y a
poder ser menor al grado y medio pero
para ello se necesitan políticas
inmediatas que cambien la actual
economía basada en los combustibles
fósiles con energías limpias como la
solar o la eólica
en 2021 por primera vez naciones unidas-
usó un lenguaje contundente frente a la
emergencia climática dijo que la
responsabilidad de la actividad humana
en el calentamiento global es inequívoca
y que solo de nosotros depende evitar
consecuencias aún más catastróficas si
les sirvió el vídeo para entender la
crisis ambiental que vivimos los
esperamos en otro episodio de en 5
minutos aquí en france 24